foreign
do you read now what is this it's
classified
oh I'm sorry
you weren't invited
nothing can stop me I Can't Get Enough
playing with dangerous bad behavior
[Music]
hey why are you here I got this
situation where I need your help
I need bad friends
cause I'm the new guy is that sniper
don't worry about it I got a
prescription oh guys remember this face
don't shoot it by accident
terrorists have taken possession of
nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off the
coast
[Applause]
but these babies go off
it'll be World War III
to choose this life over friends
over family
time to get loud
let's fly baby
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about
is that the biggest one you've got
oh it's way bigger than that
[Music]
thank you